you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network this is an
American history podcast each week I
drinker of water washer with water dumb
boy you can think of 1/3 water just for
water
Dave Anthony you read the story from
American history to his friend Gareth
Reynolds who has no idea what the topic
is about you can watch video of this
podcast on the all things comedy YouTube
page and now just shut your mouth errand
there'll be no more demands Wow you
heard him back there it got weird
when does the intro come in now the
quote is jam-packed this is sick
arguments
order in the court order I swear I mean
great work past me well I put it on
again oh it's right again yeah play it
again play it one more time get to the
broader in the court just boom because
that's you it's very funny what I said
back then do you have any dates coming
up oh yeah this Thursday I'll be at the
malt shop with Dave Anthony split one
with two straws
no no we'll get into it December 27th
through the 29th I'll be at the American
comedy club in San Diago California
January fourth fifth and six I will be
at the funny bone in Syracuse New Jersey
Aaron and post put that thumb the other
way and then we should mention January
19th we will be here in Los Angeles
performing a live dollop
everybody gets blown what is I know what
we signed up did you get the email no
we're gonna be in Phoenix will be
January night sorry 18th the night
before in Phoenix this coming weekend
we'll be in Texas so Houston's in Austin
and Dallas in Dallas Houston I'm sure
you already know we're doing a very
suspense special special special
Memorial episode to our our great hero
George HW Bush and there's been mixed
reviews from what I've read online some
people who are like oh great another
people like he knows it yeah well that's
okay because as soon as ice that's one
of the ones like as soon as I said it
you would know it yeah right so it's not
a big deal yeah write that back to those
people who have just been saying that
we're also going to be in Atlanta and
Philadelphia good adult podcast.com and
get tickets yes and we will also shortly
be putting out a few clean episodes ones
that we've already done that have been
cleaned up because some teachers are
requesting episodes they could
potentially play for students which by
the way seems like the best way to teach
all right what you learn
um and then for people with kids and
stuff okay
children's choo-choo geez you guys we
are sponsored by stamps.com as you guys
know I use stamps calm when I send
packages and do them the mailing for the
patron on which people you are going to
get before Christmas stamps calm is
super easy I I just take out the
packages I put them together I throw it
on a scale that they give me it comes up
on my computer I print it up slap it on
put out front Mammon comes gone that's
it that stamps calm tone it down you
tone it down so it's like I'm going to
post office in your house it brings all
the services of the US Post Office right
to your doorstep you can buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer like I already told
you print postage any day any time
stamps comm not only saves you time but
it saves you money
stamps.com helps you print the right
amount of postage every time and never
overpay again so we use stamps calm
because well we love it don't we yeah I
love you what and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps calm service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
without long term commitments go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
dollop that's stamps comm enter dollop
that's us
yeah yeah yeah no that's been made
already what you've already made that
clear how with the intro someone clicked
on this to listen to it
we're also sponsored by fabfitfun you
know I mean we both we're both having
special times fabfitfun is a seasonal
subscription box delivered four times a
year with full-size fashion beauty home
fitness and wellness products for just
$49.99 a box we we're enjoying them
because they're like like you almost
don't have to buy anything else for
Christmas a little bit I don't think you
need to buy anything you have an option
of either giving this to someone you
love or getting it for yourself and then
splitting it up into like three little
portions and then like you know yes
shade gifting yeah it's it's really
great if you're a gentleman for the lady
your life your lady it's for you
yeah my wife loves it everything every
time it comes she's very excited
so they got full-size products no
samples of anything fantastic value many
products also some great undereyes stuff
that I don't mind use and I don't mind
saying that I'm using I know it's
happening camera no I use the shawl yeah
you can customize each box by choosing
some products a shawl guy yeah yeah and
add-on with each box or be surprised
with each pack whatever you want so it's
great for discovering new brands and
products sign up for your fab fit fun
today fabfitfun boxes are amazing and
always sell out use our code dollop to
get $10 off your first box go to
fabfitfun comm to sign up and start
getting the box before a life well-lived
use promo code up to get $10 off your
first box that's over $200 for only
$39.99 go to fabfitfun calm and use code
doll to get $10 off your fabfitfun box
MF cubed alright what adding some spice
to these we're also sponsored by ADT ADT
can design and install a smart home just
for you backed by 24/7 protection a new
smart home at your service customized a
four year lifestyle explore the vast
number of things you can do with your
secure smart home set up custom
automations unique to your home to
automatically do things like lock the
doors and set the thermostat when you
leave even close your garage door with
from virtually anywhere
finally you can control your smart home
with the ADT app or the sound of your
voice hello door no save clearly please
closed door don't worry about installing
and configuring your system ADT will di
FY do it for you mmm they're an effin I
[Music]
love an a 80 people start for acronym I
don't want to talk to anymore ATT will
set up your home with multiple smart
home devices and security features like
indoor and outdoor cameras locks lights
garage door control even video doorbells
all I have a video talking I like all
combined from the ADT app or the sound
of your voice backed by 24/7 protection
you can get a doorman service that can
unlock the door for packages and stuff
like that friends
or a virtual doorman yeah morning sir
you can taper move in service where when
you're unpacking boxes ATT will install
your custom design system configure it
for you and show you how to get the most
of your new technology it's all
happening sure so visit att.com slash
podcasts to learn more about how adt can
design and install a secure home a smart
home just for you that's att.com
slash podcast boom we got six more her
favorite oh it's our favorite I don't
know Oh kidding it's Brooklyn and calm
oh you love sheets
I love sheets hey Gareth do you like to
sleep I yeah what yes yes yes that's why
we're sponsored by Brooklyn and dot-com
look you spend hopefully a 30-year life
in in sheets I'm aiming for a half and
if you're if you're in the Klan you
spend a lot more yeah yeah two thirds
this holiday season is a great time for
bedding abetting upgrade or for your
loved one not just you but also for your
loved one might really not look at me
yeah he loves it
talk about sorry talk about we are III
got him why don't we say we're gonna get
Brooklyn cheats my wife was like I love
them
so she sounds terrible the way I make
her sound yeah a real sweetheart
but we got a version we're a big fan
she's a big fan you got the gray ones to
hide the stains right you know you keep
you keep insinuating lies and if you
keep doing it I'll see you in court so
he got the stain ones I got the normal
white ones
it's not called stain ones but they come
in tons of color white rags or Stanners
come with tons of colors that's what I'm
saying
when are the dumbass stains best online
category by Good Housekeeping 300
thousand three and thirty thousand five
five-star reviews that's pretty good yep
that is a hundred and eighty thousand
stars they cut out the middleman so you
get a quality sheet like a five tower
five-star hotel quality sheet 240 super
cheap basically you're getting you get
more stars than in the gallic that's
what I'm talking and I don't they're
tight they also have towels robes
candles sleep masks and other
to make great gifts for the season I'm
sleeping so are Brooke my Brooklyn and
should see to the best I don't know
about yours I don't really care most
comfortable sheets I've ever slept an
awful person to work with and now it's
time for your upgrade not you Aaron
Brooklyn or kama sheets zoos have offer
just for our listeners get $20 off and
free shipping when you use promo code
the dollop at Brooklyn accom Brooklyn is
so confident in their product that all
the sheets comforters and towels come
with a lifetime warranty the only way to
get $20 off and free shipping is to use
promo code of the doll at brooklyn accom
that's be our oh oh KL i an en comm
promote the doll Brooklyn and these are
the best sheets ever so you got a couple
there's a couple of pretty sweet gift
situations there that's all I'm saying
you know in our sponsors you said a lot
more than that
I said hello but yeah for sure yeah
we're getting hearing some sheets Aaron
come over to my place tonight and test
them out and see if you like them and
then if you like them we'll get you some
okay okay
he's gonna be there yes December 24th
1936 Christmas Eve in 1936 yeah okay
that's when all the [ __ ] that's when the
best [ __ ] was happening sure Stewart
Resnick was born in middle Bush New
Jersey it's the middle of the bush sure
his father owned a bar he was a tough
guy a big drinker and a gambler Stewart
once came home and the family car was
gone dad had lost it in a bet wow that's
much of a gambler he was yeah so he
lived on the edge they never knew if
they're gonna have a home or not or a
car right could get lost in a game even
yeah quote he was tough on the outside
but inside he had these weaknesses
mm-hmm say about your pop yeah I was
thinking you would maybe have a little
more upside as far as like but at but
inside he had a good heart but inside he
was really weak his will was weak he was
terrible awful on the inside yeah
Stewart friends were all from
upper-class families he was the only
part one know when Stewart was in his
first year of college at records the
family got a call from an uncle in
California mm-hmm
he'd gotten into building strip malls
and said it was easy money how many
times have you heard that getting into
the strip mall business it's super easy
would relish living in a time where
people are like strip malls I don't know
if that's gonna work out instead of now
where it's like all strip malls yeah the
family headed out west ster went to UCLA
and joined a fraternity oh that's so fun
and one of his frat brothers his dad had
a janitorial business and Stewart his
friend bought a machine from him that
scrubbed and waxed floors okay soon they
had a cleaning business okay
Stewart then bought out his buddy
because it was doing so well
goodwill Community Care it is too good
of a cleaning yeah I don't like it when
Aaron gets a look at him
so the business takes off okay pretty
soon he's got two trucks and crews
remember he's still a student at UCLA
sure when he graduated from UCLA in 1960
he was making 40 K year which today
would be about three hundred and twenty
thousand Jesus okay that's a lot it's a
lot it's like when I got man wild it
when I got out of that college I was
like what kind of Top Ramen am I getting
and in college yeah when he he noticed
what was your ramen flavor
oh it's chicken shrimp really yeah which
which people I guess it's like a scarlet
letter yes supportive yeah I'm not not
on that night shrimp no it's just with
shrimp in a package just know I don't
want the flavor shrimp on each shrimp
I'm eat shrimp and I want the flavor
that sounds like a way to tell someone
to [ __ ] off hey what's going swimming
Billy's got to go eat some shrimp would
ya why don't you going some shrimp
flavoring buddy all right we gave the
come over and get your teeth knocked out
go eat shrimp he noticed what he was
cleaning buildings at night that there
were no guards so he decided to sell the
cleaning business and he started here to
become the bad guy from dying Robert
okay he started skirting abyss he sold
his cleaning business for 2.5 million
and he's like it early 20s yeah he's
just out of Law School
Wow ok so a little later ok so Linda
Linda Linda Ray Harris was born in 1942
and raised in Philadelphia ok hey Phil
are you doing nobody supports this he
her dad was a film distributor and when
she was 15 her dad moved to LA to be a
movie producer so Linda and Stuart
Stuart inland okay right so her dad
produced The Blob 1958 one of the best a
great movie best my favorite movie about
gelatin eating people by far the best
one it's that and the rest of all the
gelatin movie yeah yeah it costs two
hundred and forty thousand dollars to
make and eventually grossed more than a
hundred times that so he's rolling it
yeah
Lindo is now a kid living in Beverly
Hills after high school she wanted to go
to art school but her father refused to
help with tuition so instead she got a
job working in a dress shop The Blob man
was like I'm not gonna help you go to
school he was cool okay if he had done
that none of this might have happened
well I don't know what's about to happen
she started making ads for the store and
was very good at it okay so she went
into well she went into working in
advertising
okay great and while she's doing all
this what up and told you creating a
great sort of character type someone who
grew up in Beverly Hills with money and
then went into advertising I mean if you
meet this person get next to him at a
party you're gonna want to hear about
them so while she's doing all this she
got married and had kids right so by the
time she was 24 Linda had started her
own advertising agency called Linda
limited and was divorced with three kids
interesting okay so that's a lot of it's
a lot it's a different time yeah a lots
going on early because now if you're 24
you're like man what am I gonna move out
yeah now you're like man what am I gonna
get that shrimp ramen mm-hmm love it
just a regular person is like man that
shrimp around there about that yum yum
yum so at this point Stuart Resnick was
also divorced and had three kids wait a
minute he needed some advocates a story
of a man named Stuart yep oh boy yeah he
needs some advertising work and someone
recommended Linda okay they were married
in 1973 okay
Stuart's guard company landed a big
contract to handle security at LAX all
right they guarded incoming
international air planes until the
planes can be inspected by customs okay
three of the airport guards where
wrested selling two pounds of heroin
that's illegal back then it was okay
Stewart said it was a few bad apples in
the company and they had already been
fired okay yeah but but the federal
organized crime and racketeering strike
force started investigating the company
for quote possible infiltration of
airport security by organized crime Wow
the LA Times quote during the seven
during the five-month investigation that
led to the arrests several of the
suspects told undercover agents they had
access to a large supply as much as a
hundred pounds at a time of the oriental
heroin which they said was being shipped
into this country on commercial airlines
and and and that gives the undercover
guys some information that that shows
that maybe heroin is being brought into
the country illegally through them right
okay a little bit and so it's a
successful sting operation yeah like
when you're going through that you're
like hey man why'd you get such a beauty
just now he's like nothing just I keep
that talking more to my chest
Stewart sold the business moved into the
alarm business there's no guards okay
then he sold the alarm company for 100
millions and now is where the rise yeah
he's kind of moving up in the world yeah
so they got into agriculture in 1978
buying 2,500 acres of orange trees in
Kern County California hmm I'm a little
bit of a switch yeah and I'm also I'm a
little now I'm starting to be suspect
mm-hmm because I don't like the numbers
that are being thrown out as I do the
math the state was experiencing a
horrible drought and they were able to
get the land cheap Stewart quote they
were selling twenty five hundred acres
of oranges and lemons and the packing
house for third of their appraised value
it was simply a place to park some money
and have another opportunity I think it
paid nine million I think I paid nine
million I think yeah make it remember
nine or ten it's hard to keep track of a
million yeah like it's like a backpack
you bought on Craigslist
I guess 13 I can't remember in 1978 they
bought Teleflora a flower delivery
company mm-hmm Linda turned into a very
lucrative business by sewing the flowers
in a glass vase or a teep
or at with a teddy bear some other [ __ ]
it was said as she revolutionized the
flower delivery service so stupid yeah
so she's like I T ah oh my god you're
gonna sell something else with flowers
oh my lord
this woman's a genius I don't know how
she thought of this wait a teddy bear
with the flowers oh please
let me lay down on this couch go get a
wet rag oh my lord I'm gonna pass out
flowers in a teapot by doom everything's
so now they have a parent company called
roll International mm-hmm
on November 4 17 sorry 1979 a group of
Iranian students stormed the US Embassy
in Teheran taking more than 60 American
hostages mm-hmm
President Carter imposed sanctions on
Iran Iran a long been known for
producing the world's best pistachios
very buttery very yummy everybody loves
an Iranian pistachio this is this
seriously being highlighted for a reason
or you're just okay but now now yeah
they have the best pistachios yeah very
buttery pistachios yeah I'm gonna show
you this is the Resnick's oh my god
they're older I can find the young
pictures of them but there they are look
like now well she's got that you know
kind of maybe a little nip/tuck going on
he's like I'm aging she's not
so now pistachios can't be sold in
America right because they're sanctions
okay so the Resnick's opportunity and
with a horrendous drought that had
occurred in 1976 and 1977 in California
oil companies like Mobil and Texaco are
trying to get their pistachio and almond
orchards that they own for cheap okay
these were huge 20,000 and 40,000 acre
plots of land so they bought more and
more acreage through the 80s Stewart and
Linda did okay for rock-bottom prices
droughts always made land more
affordable in 1986 they bought they
bought Franklin Mint a commemorative
coin and medallion business for 160 7.5
Linda turned into something much bigger
diving into Julie dolls model cars soon
I put some of the coins and a tape ha
and but she did something like the
Shibata she bought at auction
Jackie Kennedy's pearls at Joy's war was
really fake and she but she bought him
at an auction for two hundred ten
thousand like everyone in the world made
fun of her there's actually a Dewar's ad
made about her that was like her did you
just buy fake pearls for two hundred and
ten thousand or yeah okay and then she
made like [ __ ] fifty million off of
selling replicas like so she yeah so
they made it shut up now doors where are
you now doers huh
but printed a retraction so pretty soon
annual sales of the Franklin Mint hit 1
billion my god and presidents kept
pushing for tougher sanctions on Iran
and the Resnick's kept buying farmland
by the end of the 80s the residents had
a hundred thousand acres in 1987 they
bought eighteen thousand acres from
Prudential Life Insurance part of that
was a hundred and eighty acres of
pomegranates the these these enormous
companies just owned and like huge plots
either for nuts or I don't know look I
know the oil companies had it because
they wanted the oil that was under the
ground and then they're also like why
don't we also have a farm like just use
the land to make money that's kid I
don't know why an insurance company
would have yeah a foreign land
alright boys that's twelve thirty water
and break get up there now boys get out
there get them nuts off thing trees and
still some life insurance on guys what
are the pomegranates so they had 180
acres of pomegranates he was gonna rip
them up but one of those workers like
just keep them and see what happens
keep them there like a puzzle that you
can eat so water in California is a big
deal oh no is this where we're headed
mm-hmm and the way it works is a [ __ ]
mess the state's laws were designed to
settle the frontier so there's a first
guy gets in gets the water rights rule
so the first guy to get to wherever gets
to own the wash so we have it as like
the Black Friday rules
it's [ __ ] murder and one guy this guy
named Miller literally
went and just [ __ ] got all the water
of the state at one point like he just
he just got everything he owned like all
the [ __ ] water at one point so it's
called senior rights right those are
senior rights okay most senior water
rights claims are the last to be
restricted during droughts so if you
have senior water rights and there's a
drought on you still get water and other
people don't so some farmers can still
flood their fields while residents of
towns like Oakville and East Porterville
have to truck in water so East
Porterville has no water whatsoever and
they have to truck in all their water
well that's where that's a situation
there where farmers get to pump their
water also large urban areas would get
water over many farmers so like la
insanity of water over a lot of the
farmers right okay but it's super
complicated in 1960 California created
the state water water project the swp
takes water from rivers in the north and
sends it to the dry south through
aqueducts pipelines and tunnels you've
seen that when you drive out of the five
there's a big big aqueduct but it was
never completed okay it's supposed to
deliver for four point two three sorry
four point two three million acres of
water a year but has only been able to
deliver 2.4 million acres of water
because it's not fully done okay so when
droughts happen
the swp rules say water should go to
urban areas first and farms could get
cut off and have to use aquifers that
seems smart
the Kern County where most of the
Resnick's land is gets water a lot of
water from the swp and then another
another organization but in 1988 the
Department of Water Resources bought an
aquifer along the Kern River to store
surplus water for drought years so they
bought this huge piece of land okay
underneath is just this giant aquifer
okay and and in and in that they're
gonna store water right here it is okay
well it looks it looks very fertile yeah
so
so it's called the current water bank
okay in plus years you just keep dumping
water in there when there's a drought
right you can take it out right right
cost the savings account it cut yeah
it's a water savings account but yeah if
that helps does that help
it helps Eren Mikasa States seventy five
million okay which would be like a
hundred forty million today so after
couple more droughts Stuart Resnick and
others were unhappy they weren't getting
all the water they wanted Dave I have a
feeling I'm about to really not like
Stuart and Linda now they had junior
water rights so that's senior guys are
ahead of them okay right and and they
had to get around him so a lawsuit was
threatened against the DWR department
water resources and as the has the bank
and it's led by Stuart it's a coalition
of guys led by Stuart and they said this
state wasn't delivering the four point
two three million what acres of water
was supposed to which is true it's not
great can't right he's not fully built
right so the DWR and the coalition had a
secret meeting in Monterey California
where Stuart Resnick proposed a solution
California could give the water bank to
the Westside mutual water company which
is just a thing Stuart owns I was and
five water districts of all big AG big
big AG guys okay the west side meet your
water company is owned by the Resnick's
and all the water districts are
controlled by agribusiness including
paramount which is the Resnick's farm
company so now is he gonna guess he does
he one of the six but then he also
controls another one so he's two of the
six really in return the Resnick's would
give up their junior water rights which
is water that doesn't exist anyway so
they are sacrificing so there's nothing
to get a ton so the threat they're
threatening to sue because they're not
getting water that they should doesn't
exist right because it's never been
built right into the system right but
the system at the beginning was supposed
to like legally supposed to send that
much water down so they're so they're
saying so from - from zero the chili
from zero to two there's actual water
right from two to four there's no water
and that's where their water comes from
so they say they'll stop the lawsuit and
give up the two to four water which
doesn't exist if the if the state hands
over the water and and who is
negotiating on behalf of the state it's
not great okay so okay
nobly now so so he also says the state
can just pretend that the extra water
exists this feels foolhardy as far as
pretending extra water existed this
became known as paper water what is
happening yes that's right so they
create origami go so they've created
something called paper water which is
water that doesn't exist
I can run water you [ __ ] but legally
it does exist no it doesn't dick what
legally it does on paper it's water no
it's you're supposed to get the for
April I'll get the dollar you let the
paper go let's get the 4.2 million so so
you have rights to water even though
it's not real you know it's hard for you
to throw out facts and then advocate for
the other side I'm like feels like you
have an evil twin it's yourself okay so
the state went for it good and I say we
close this deal up boy it ain't gonna
get worse and just gave up the water
bank paid for by public money what
created by the public it is now
privatized it is just given away what
year was this this is 1994 Oh
all happens behind closed doors all
deals are out done behind closed doors
governor is Wilson Republican ever since
that day 1994 California's been
operating as if water that does not
exist is real that's not good why
because we're low already to make a
large real estate development in
California you legally have to prove you
have a water source available so if you
want to build a bunch of houses you got
to prove that there's water to go to
those people okay so now developers
could just buy paper water from farmers
and start building
houses oh no on top of all this the
state agreed there would no longer be a
requirement that the water be scaled
back for farms during droughts oh god oh
god so it's literally the shittiest deal
I've ever heard of by a state in the
history it's vanishing it's it's the
worst deal ever
what who closed it I mean there's nobody
[ __ ] knows Nate in the room nobody
knows who's in the room nobody knows who
was in there you know resident was in
there and some other guys but we don't
know who the [ __ ] was in there so
suddenly for some strange reason Linda
and Stuart Resnick became huge farmers
they nearly doubled their land holdings
over the next three years by 1996 the
Resnick's owned more than a hundred
thousand acres of pistachios and almonds
sales were about 1.5 billion and they
had so much power and so much control
over water
that other huge farming families called
on the state to intervene okay right
yeah sure one was John a she fit of it
right
Wow this guy John missa [ __ ] is the
Vista pitcher of it a [ __ ] will know
right here we pull it up probably all
right so that's one of the guys okay so
I think it's bit of it she's a bit of it
so he's but he's been as far as a farmer
he's been buying up insane amounts of
property always near rivers or over
large aquifers right so he's he likes
real water
he likes real water so he accused the
Resnick's of using shell companies to
monopolize control of the current water
bank which is what exactly what they did
right a public resource have been
privatized for the purpose weird for a
pistachio to have a shell company keep
going so we get a symbol I don't think
so rim shot so a public resource has
been privatized for the purpose of
growing tens of thousands of acres of
nuts he charged okay he's gonna take him
to court okay and then vinovich suddenly
ono went to see Stuart no I'm like
lawsuit was dry I liked him right away
damn it now other companies when I fall
I fall hard
now other companies took a look what the
red
the a kept get kept Auto cracking into
ret rednecks so though Resnick's had
done with the water bank okay and
decided that was a good way to make a
buck in 1998 a company named Enron
bought a British Water Company for two
billion dollars you are literally and
running water they renamed the company
ezarik s' I kind of missed when I knew
nothing it's kind of a simpler time as
uruk's bought the huge Madera ranch in
the San Joaquin Valley the ranch was on
top of a giant aquifer that could hold
480 billion acres of water okay The Wall
Street Journal quote Osric Corp is
launched in exchange on the internet for
buying selling storing and transporting
water in the West hoping to make water a
traded commodity much like natural gas
or electricity Enron wanted people to
invest in water paper water
oh those they were just they lived they
worked in imagined town and runs old
business motto is like yes but have you
heard of [ __ ] it's way easier
okay so Enron is and running water
basically right the idea was to sell
aquifer storage space in this aquifer so
farmers would send their when they had
excess water like a year there's a lot
of rain they could send the excess water
to the storage they pay to keep it there
oh and then when they need it they could
get the water back at the same time no
no no the same time they're getting
water from the state that water they can
sell and not a lot of that water is
paper water right so they can sell it to
a guy who wants to build you you are
like three-card Monte in your mouth
right now but no so they can sell their
fake water to a guy who wants to build a
build a town or a development it's fine
why is this a problem this is early and
this is a train wreck so you know you
when you need to get your water in a
drought year you go back to Enron's
water bank save water leave it or not
that doesn't sound likely so it all
sounds good right so from the guy the
opposite from my time the guy running it
quote so the way that water trading
works is that you're not really actually
trading the actual water molecule so
wait wait buddy pal so I have this
amount of water uh-huh and now let's
swap it in such a way that I get access
to water when I need it but it's not the
actual water that's going there it's an
avocation of water huh so I have I I'm
owed water so I'm gonna sell that to you
and then that's yours if it ever is the
thing I just want my water that I gave
yeah yeah I don't know if we can do that
but let's why don't you trade it or sell
it to somebody else
it just sounds way worse
trust me son it's much better than
trying to take it we don't have it what
was at the end there yep I like doing
business with you okay
hey I gotta close up the bank it's 3:00
my water yeah the local farmers however
were on to it and did not fall for it
they organised and told as uruk's to
[ __ ] off and eventually Enron and as
uruk's had to give up and go home
well but they did try it in Texas
Florida and Argentina also and they
failed in all three places they lost one
point six million can we end the episode
now because there's been a huge victory
so I'm gonna get better farmer in 1998
the Resnick's family doctor told them
that the pomegranate was revered in folk
medicine
oh there's 180 acres of yeah Granite's
so they funded a study by an Israeli
doctor at Tech nion University amazingly
quote we found that the juice had more
antioxidants than we'd ever found in red
wine they funded more studies Linda
quote the news was off the charts
the Resnick's decided to make
pomegranate juice oh my god in 2001 they
also planted seedless mandarins mm-hmm
but bees from nearby orchards were
flying into the Resnick's groves and if
you pollinate a flower of a
get seats if they're not pollinated
let's play a little God well Stuart told
us neighboring farmers to change which
way the bees were flying or he'd sue
them for trespassing wait wait wait wait
he whoops yep go ahead are you a crazy
man with all the money is telling other
farmers to control their bees have you
ever seen a rich welcome to be leashes
have you ever seen a rich person who
thinks that they can tell everything
what to do well this guy wants to
control bees I just I think and yes
there are a lot of entitled people out
there but normally people are able to
see lines at the hive what are your
insects doing buddy get him out of here
all right listen all right listen guys
I'm gonna make this short and sweet
obviously you've turned your bees
against me and my seedless mandarins
stop being [ __ ]
call off your bees otherwise I'm sending
my army of wasps okay I see one more bee
I'm gonna [ __ ] up you I'm gonna [ __ ] up
your hive oh honey I'm at ease beside
these fists made for bees hold on I'm
gonna go grab one of these bees all
right buddy
who do you work for which farmer do you
work for little bee yeah all right well
maybe you don't want to talk now but a
punch to the begun yeah yeah be fine hon
yeah what happened to me okay so they've
invented pomegranate juice because of
via enca antioxidants that are now off
the charts and they're trying to control
ways yes the China controls me the
farmers whose land the bees came from I
mean the bead directors said they
couldn't control the bees flight path so
they're giving that talking point
interesting and then they threatened to
sue Resnick back okay so finally Resnick
just put netting up around his mandarins
that bees could not picture make it a
driving race that's how that went for
sure okay now his now their the
Resnick's mandarins are called halos if
you've ever seen them in every grocery
store
California I go to the rumors okay but
there's two kinds of eye nose mom and
renters right yeah their halos and their
cuties yeah and the two they used to
have there was them and somebody else
have these orchards together and sold
them all those cuties and then the
Resnick split off because they can't
work with anybody right
no so palm the pomegranate juice was
launched in 2002 oh no these are the
palm people at that time only 4% of
Americans had tasted a pomegranate okay
Linda kicked in and mark and marketed
palm as an anti antioxidant rich miracle
food that might improve cardiovascular
health fight prostate cancer erectile
dysfunction and even prevent Alzheimer's
disease so you're gonna have a strong
body [ __ ] and you'll remember a lot of
stuff yeah you [ __ ] like I'm right now
you're not getting sick good heart and
and yeah and most of this is just sort
of what's from the studies that her own
money paid for right paper studies so
the residents had become Hollywood
players and big in the Democratic Party
they live in Beverly Hills
Linda quote I have David Bowie and you
know ruber Murdock and some are red
stone who else well alright David Bowie
get off the list I know everybody's on
her list Mike Milken you know just
famous people Oh Jay Simpson Mel Gibson
Anna Nicole Smith the day Lister's the
normal people all the heads of the
Hollywood studios so everyone she knows
gets samples of palm before it launches
and she's keeps sending him and people
are just they're all drinking him shows
up my TV shows like Desperate Housewives
queer Scientology the beverage yeah
basically where I are their swag bags
the Grammys the Emmys the Golden Globes
the palm tini became a featured cocktail
at the Oscars so pom takes off it was
healing food okay right which is no
different than what we've talked about
before with the crazy healing cures oh
yeah but like electric water or whatever
yeah it's all the same [ __ ] the national
marketing campaign showed a palm bottle
with a broken noose
around its neck under the slogan cheat
death oh my god
settle down I didn't get that but here
by the way and that is such a like that
is yeah yeah that's that's what you seen
here where the salad dressings are yeah
yes they fought to get it put in the
penalty section she said it's a living
food yeah it also it's just like so easy
to make people in Hollywood believe [ __ ]
yeah it's the easiest thing in the world
I got a swag bag
hey this is ja Rule all I do is drink
pom
all right thanks ja that's awesome
in 2004 the Resnick's bought fiji water
the thickest plastic bottled water there
is in 1995 the previous owner had gotten
a 99 year lease over a 17 mile aquifer
in fiji with a tax-free status from a
wizard who gives that deal yeah because
he said i'll bring jobs but he said the
water the bottled water business is too
risky
and they went for it the tax breaks
supposed to end in 2008 so in four years
after they bought it right so fiji water
takes off when the previous guy had i
think it was the third third most
selling one but fiji still super
poverty-stricken island the owner called
fiji square bottles quote
little ambassadors for the onions of
fiji and full of bpa as soon as the
Reznick spot feature they push the
bottles into celebrities hands at every
opportunity
now these dumb morons hey with a cast of
friends this is all we drink i mean to
thieve common al gore's hand and [ __ ]
like they've got him in hands you're
like you shouldn't be in your hand it
was on The Sopranos 24 the view
Desperate Housewives soon Fiji was the
number one selling bottled water in the
US we were just having fun though we
were just a bunch of kids who were
excited to have bottles of water with us
you know no longer living by the
shackles of the bubbler being able to
walk around with some water that's all
we wanted we just wanted a simple treat
on a hot summer's day I know you're
something when you're on a road when
you're sitting in traffic you don't have
time to pull over and drink from a
goddamn river but imagine there's a god
if there is a God and he comes back she
and she comes back and she goes now tell
me about this and you go okay so so we
go to this island in the middle of the
ocean you build and we take water you
already know everything why are you
making us tell you and then we and then
we get there's these guys that are
called China you know the Chinese guys
are Chinese guys they live over there
and they make bottles for us and there's
soup and different metal ball and then
we put the bottle we put the water in
bottles and then we put on chips and we
take it across the ocean and then we all
drink it here I don't think she'd be
happy and then she goes why I gave you
water where you are I know but this is
in little square bottles yeah but
they're little bit let me let me handle
this mark their little baby ambassadors
we like to look at each thick thick
plastic and by the way just let you know
a lot of these bottles end up back in
the ocean yeah where water and then
there's no ubiquitous right it doesn't
matter and so the Fiji water goes home
to the middle of the ocean on the island
the people in Fiji don't have they're
like poor so oh yeah is that how you
wanna know they're on an awesome
Oh your all-seeing all-knowing you
obviously know you made the Fijians poor
yeah and they are so happy to have their
their resources stolen they love it
they're really into it they like when we
take their stuff oh yeah no we've got a
bunch of them who will say that you know
yeah but Andy whose will be we should
get moving
we go every time a trafficker and it is
off for time it's a Friday about that
and there's seven okey-dokey oh these
guys oh absolutely you'll love them
Nestle's great they make chocolate kill
people it's unbelievable so Cynthia
becomes the number one bottled water
bottle southern company in the you
the slogan was quote well kill
everything and remember this we saved
you a trip to Fiji like the worst part
thank you like going to Fiji and like go
to Fiji is some sort of pennies a day
without us you'd have to go there it's
nice though it's a violent shut up and
drink your bottle and in paradise shut
up yep yep the Resnick's also
relentlessly attacked tap water calling
it quote not a real viable alternative
it's true that you can't drink it that
it can contain four thousand
contaminants which Fiji's quote living
water did not this is just and these are
repeated talking points these are things
that I've now don't know they've yeah
you know I didn't even I think I forgot
to put this in here but they eventually
yeah they got [ __ ] on that too like
they they won't play they said our
waters like they made fun of Cleveland
and Cleveland water they did tests and
it's more pure than Fiji bottled water
yeah but it saved you a trip to
Cleveland Linda wrote quote you can no
longer trust public or private water
supplies yeah yeah trust this
billionaire who's called pomegranate
juice the thing that will cure your
cancer pistachios were also becoming
bigger and bigger sellers but the
Resnick's knew if relations with Iran
ever normalized the country could sell
its potala statius again which are far
stronger sweet God the nuts are so much
better the Iranian nuts are so much
better than America is that Israelis buy
Iranian pistachios shipped through
Turkey and rebranded so the Resnick's
started sending money to right-wing
think tanks and advocacy advocacy
advocacy advocacy groups that push for
hardline approaches on Iran this is just
now becoming a cartoon-like foreign
policy based upon pistachio butteriness
capitalism this includes economic
sanctions sabotage and vilification
between 1999 and 2004 the Resnick
Foundation funneled 1.125 million to the
American Jewish Committee one of the
most active lobbyists pushing for Iran
sanctions bill that was passed in 2009
other groups pushing for the sanctions
were Halliburton exxon mobil and
lockheed martin i gotta go a list at
like satan's barbecue and run a lockheed
welcome welcome welcome
the Resnick's also give money to the
Washington Institute for Near East
policy think-tank which calls for heavy
sanctions and military strikes against
Iran what must it be like to have this
much money I think you stop having any
feeling you completely lose conscience
you have no feeling as a human being
Stewart is also a board member of the
American friends of IDC a non-for-profit
foundation that is the fundraising arm
of a think tank with close ties to the
Israeli intelligence and military
establishment American Friends of IDC
gave 10 million to the think tank in
2006 we do not know how much the
Resnick's gave but Stewart is a board
member
along with Vegas tycoon Sheldon Adelson
oh my god pomegranate juice buy though
here's the Fuji plant and there it is
making that's where they make the water
and it's it's really beautiful the
facility background man Linda says
others are just saving me a trip to
their yeah sure Linda says other people
are jealous of their pistachio success
quote we've done more for the pistachio
than anyone ever since it was planted in
the Garden of Eden oh sorry
can we just murder that sentence yeah oh
no oh they do the second one my husband
should be canonized for all the work
he's done oh my god by the way the
mechana guys canonizing people for nut
quality for a long time just you're deep
in the pistachio game when you're
talking like this mm-hmm you know I'm
the Martin Luther King of pistachios so
so just so just so people understand
what sanctions do sanctions kill people
sanctions kill children and people who
need medicine they kill people that's
what sanctions do they they really hurt
the poor and they kill the poor another
country so when they're trying to make
money off their pistachios they're
killing people they're begging for
sanctions based on their nuts yeah nuts
in 2006 the Fiji government was
overthrown in a military coup okay the
Resnick's just kept doing business in
the country saying they were helping the
people by giving them jobs environmental
activists targeted fiji water for
bottling water on a pacific island with
oil made from bottles in china and
talking [ __ ] about tap water linda
responded with a new Fiji slogan quote
every drop is green it shouldn't be what
you label tap water she started she's
turned an ad campaign called Fiji green
that urged people to drink imported
water to fight climate change Oh Mike
it's Jay you know sometimes you just
gotta go so far off the spectrum to hit
a home run you know what I mean it's
almost like you took a swing missed the
ball but then when the bat crossed
behind you accidentally bunted you know
like you've just gotta like you know oh
yeah well we're ruining the world well
how about this by Fiji water to save the
world [ __ ] how about that it's really
the Fiji green website claims a 120
percent carbon offset and says that
buying a large bottle of Fiji water
creates the same carbon reduction
walking five blocks instead of driving
hello I'm doctor hostage Jesus so if you
drink your feed you today walk five
blocks okay the company insists that the
water bottles travel on ships that would
be making the trip any
so that doesn't count empty ships just
making the trip well what do you say we
turn around to do it again with nothing
on board
well old times sake they wait did I
mention the Resnick's on Neptune Pacific
line a shipping company
no I didn't Oh were they also on that so
maybe the right maybe the ships are
going that way anyway they're not
likable in 2008 that the way they were
the way they were factoring it all was
they were like it was like there's this
there's this way that certain companies
do we're good for climate change we're
good for carbon emissions is they like
do it like it's like a decade four
decades ahead formula so it's like so
they're able you look at this over nine
decades we're actually pretty good right
so these this map that's just like
[ __ ] nonsense in future decades yeah
yeah future decades like so they're like
so nine decades down the road oh it all
works out the Enron genie refusing to go
back in the bottle again in 2008 the tax
break Fiji had given had given the the
water company was set to expire the
government tried to impose a tax fiji
water called it quote draconian and shut
down the plant okay the government gave
in fiji water never called the military
Hunta controlling the island draconian
just the attempt to get taxes the
military declared martial law in 2009
okay in California the Resnick's water
bank ownership was paying off in spades
when drought struck in 2007 the
Resnick's 48 percent stake in the
current water bank became even more
valuable the AP reported that the
Reznick share of the water bank amounted
to two hundred and forty six billion
gallons enough to supply all the
residents of San Francisco for 16 years
okay they were able to expand and water
all of their orchards now each nut oh
yeah it takes a gallon of water yeah
each nut and they're insanely thirsty
you know that needs to be in this day
and age instead of calorie counts that's
what needs to be listed next to the food
item how much water how much 100 stake
to produce
so they also sold water so the Resnick's
are selling water what do they need what
that's in the water bang dime bags when
they got ounces moving they're selling
water to the state of California that is
the this just further proves how bad
this deal is I say we take it why did
you say yes to this look alright they're
pretty shrewd I say we just let's move
on this deal I don't know how much
better it's gonna get so this is water
the stated owned a Dave and just gave
way to the people now charging them for
the water they're giving us a great deal
from 2000 to 2007 the state of
California paid the Resnick's thirty
point six million dollars for water and
the water was used to protect native
fish the delta smelt in the fragile
sacramento-san Joaquin Delta so they're
saving a fish that's a key a key animal
in the food chain okay super key animal
in the food chain and so they're selling
water but again I think this is allotted
water because they can't take water from
the water bank
move it up I think it's just an
allotment of water so they're not taking
the water that's going down the river
and they're like yeah you can have that
we'll just sell it to you we just are
not allowed to be shocked when we live
in Mad Max in 2010 the Fiji government
said it was going to increase taxes
again raising the tax on bottled water
about eight cents in US money you'll
have to walk three more blocks yeah of
the Fiji bottle taxes were only bringing
in five hundred thousand dollars a year
and this would raise it to twenty two
million okay
the Resnick's making hundreds of
millions a year from Fiji water not
including all their other businesses
weren't about to pony up how could they
they're their net worth was 1.3 billion
dollars
how could they give up 22 million a year
yeah the Resnick's immediately shut down
the Fiji water plant and laid off the
400 Fijian employees armed guards took
over the plant the Fiji water president
said this was quote a
clear and unmistakable message to
businesses operating in Fiji or looking
to invest there the country is
increasingly unstable and is becoming a
very risky place in which to invest how
about existence quality of existence to
the to do to do that to human beings and
graduated some military Hunta and
whatnot but that island needs money and
you're [ __ ] taking their water and
you have 1.3 billion dollars and it's
the story we've heard a number of times
on this where it is it's just this level
of theft and and now there's and now
they're calling out to the rest of the
world that it's a shitty place right yes
yes hurting further business ventures
because that's all that matters
so challenging the res next I'm gonna
not you okay
okay challenge the Resnick's is not a
thing that usually goes well now I'm
glad we're doing allegedly there was a
there was a pistachio Commission that
like very serious well you know like the
milk Commission and stuff where they do
it was easy excuse me ma'am can we just
borrow a moment I'm one with the PC the
pistachio coalition look we're in a
woman's last time you saw your husband
pistachio coalition yeah we broadened
our reach we're also doing murder
investigate anyway look the port ma'am
take a seat husband has been murdered
actually the first time I've had to let
someone down from this you might have a
crack one of these go for it
this is a table he's kind of a hothead
but he's also a puppy dog so there's a
pistachio Commission they basically
handled a with a PC are you guys do it
open up PC with a pistachio coalition
what kind of nuts you got your nut
drawer so they handle advertising right
it's all the farmers get together and
they decide what kind of had it and so
when that when the Resnick's got control
of 65 percent of pistachios they killed
the Commission so they would just handle
the marketing themselves sure this is
how monopolies get to have fun that's
right so one guy in the Commission said
quote Stuart wants to be a benevolent
dictator if he thinks you're defined to
be yeah
if he thinks you're defying him he'll
start with nobody realizes the good I've
done for agriculture and then he moves
on to Do You Know Who I am do you know
what I am I'm a billionaire that's cool
that's super cool to hear it doesn't
matter who the billionaire is if a
billionaire ever says I'm a billionaire
legally you can kick them in the nuts as
hard as you want right in the pistachio
right in the pistachios I'm like how
you're saying I'm gonna continue the
quote he's got an awful temper he's
trying to control through Kabbalah Dave
we're checking a lot of boxes here I
mean I don't know when the deuce of the
year is but uh so the P R from this Fuji
shut down is not good right and the
quotes that they're saying people read
right through so there's a backlash so
the day after shutting down the plant
the Resnick's relent and accept the tax
increase because it's $20 and they make
one point day every give them some
credit that's so cool none of the
so-called helped the regs and the
Resnick's give Fiji has stopped
outbreaks of typhoid on the islands
typhoid fever is endemic their incidents
have been increasing over the last
decade what does that do to the
investment brass but recent recent
research identified the transmissions
the transmission of typhoid is
predominantly through the consumption of
contaminated surface water and unwashed
produce if only the people of Fiji had a
source of water so they're taking their
aquifer water and the Fijians
are drinking I assume out of reservoirs
that are giving them typhoid how many
blocks are they walking five so they're
saving they gotta pick it up gotta pick
it up I don't think that's how you cure
type for it no you gotta walk mmm ten
blocks and jump okay yeah that's fair
gram is really small island though they
should just open their own typhoid kind
of water I mean that's what that's what
the Resnick's did okay
sorry for liking these people I'm sorry
nosotros Smith I know a winner that same
year the Federal Trade Commission ruled
that palms ads of health cures were not
true weird
the FTC said palm had overhyped the
juices ability to prevent heart disease
prostate cancer and erectile dysfunction
yeah my dick still won't get hard you
liars I drank so much palm and I can't
[ __ ] I've been slinging the whole hour
Linda quote Linda quote I think it was
unfair and I think it's a tragedy if the
fresh fruits and vegetables that are
really the medicine chest of the 21st
century have to adhere to the same rules
as a drug that could possibly harm you
the residents live in a house oh I don't
want to see it cuz I'm gonna go burn it
in Beverly Hills that's not a house that
is valued at 25 million dollars
earth on earth Island Journal quote the
Beverly Hills home looks more like an
embassy than a house seriously they
entertain the rich and famous there
they've expanded the house by buying up
and tearing down three adjacent
properties an author who wrote a book
about over-the-top houses called it
quote exaggerated extravagant crude
ridiculous and a bit indecent there is a
seven-foot a marble statue of Napoleon
in their drawing-room sorry they made
Napoleon's seven feet the marble statues
had to reinforce the floor to put the
statue in you know we're taking water
from Waterloo spring gold is everywhere
Legg gold furniture paintings and gold
frames gold leaf carpet ceilings with
gold leaf molding Nate and gold fridge
Dre new money am i right new I mean it's
just [ __ ] awful God could you imagine
what the [ __ ] why would you live in that
yeah it's just like most the [ __ ]
table yeah living in a museum it's just
a gold ring table it's like a crown
table it really
is the the height of when you're
obsessed with possessions it's no longer
matters what your livability or quality
is it's what a stranger's thing well you
when you when you think about the
revolution you and your head picture
these these rich people eating grapes
and dancing around like there's no
difference but now this and and the Fiji
well and the disparity is now it's
rising to the surface more and more so
we will you know like we just need to if
I were an investor right now I'd invest
in pikes huge foreheads I'm sure but the
Resnick's were about to become givers
now they're philanthropist they've gone
given to they give to museums and and
hey so we took all your water here's the
statue they did like some neuro wing in
the UCLA or something for neurological
disorders okay Linda's story what
happened in 2010 that really made them
change and help people is that they were
at a dinner party with a Harvard
professor by the way I mean talk about a
relatable premise it was an ethicist
okay some of the senses you said read
like mad libs what well having dinner
with an ethicist is such a [ __ ] rich
person thing to do now hey let's have an
ethicist over and he'll see well we'll
just talk and see how we're doing I
wouldn't use that fork why there's a
downside you're not thinking of what a
nightmare
that much pepper that's really sarcastic
a rude are you ready for this no he
asked the guests if they would be happy
living in a town that was perfect in
every possible way except for one
terrible secret everyone in the town
knew that somewhere in that village in a
dank basement there is a small
six-year-old child who is being tortured
and you couldn't say anything about the
torture because if you did you had to
leave the town sorry Todd of the prime
rib I don't know but I want to put a pin
in this I can't imagine what they this
is like that that movie premise where
it's like if you hit a button someone
died he said you don't know so
essentially our
okay knowing the truth in order for your
life to be perfect that's what I'm
saying are you basing your ignoring the
truth right that but by then getting
when he's sitting with a bunch of rich
people saying by you guys getting all
this you're [ __ ] over people surely
charging sixty five thousand dollars for
this dinner
Linda quote and it changed my life that
very day they would do good from then on
now I'm sure this sudden philanthropy
was because of a harbor Harvard
professor and a nothing new to do with a
story written by reporter John Kibler in
the earth Island Journal just months
before it was about the farm workers in
the town of Lost Hills Kern County the
farm workers of the Resnick's farm quote
the farm workers have lost hills live in
mobile homes and cannot drink the water
from their taps the crops they tend
drink better and cheaper water than they
do lost Hills is a 21st century company
town there is no bank no pharmacy no
local government the nearest place to
deposit a check or go to a supermarket
is Wasco 20 miles away
nearly everyone Labor's in the field for
a minimum wage nearly everyone in the
town worked for the Resnick's the Los
Angeles Business Journal estimates the
Resnick's worth at one point seven nine
billion dollars one guy who worked 58
hours a week at $1 an hour was asked how
many of the field workers were
undocumented quote if not one at a
percent than the majority the workers
all complained about low wages one had
been fired after injuring his knee on
the job one woman said quote these are
hunger wages the reporter called the
roll international office to ask for an
interview the receptionist said the
company didn't give information to the
public the reporter asked who he should
address his research questions to quote
I suggest you don't research us and she
hung up the workers in los Hills have no
clean water source have to buy bottled
water which costs them 50 to $100 a
month they have to buy bottled water for
50 to $100 a month while working for the
number one water bottlers in the [ __ ]
world they really did bring Fiji here
though
Jesus and the Resnick's had me roll all
that gridding teeth when you're buying
bottles of water the Residex also had
control of seven hundred and fifty five
thousand acre-feet of water in the Curan
water back at that time oh my god I mean
they need an onsite ethicist it needs to
be like a gardener you need a team of
ethicists Linda can we talk to you real
quick that's an awful thing you're doing
oh it is have you heard of a soul
replacement
no how much I'll throw money at this so
the Resnick's began spending fifty to
eighty million a year on philanthropy
for poor people and they started
strangely enough with their own workers
and lost Hills
that's not charity we've decided to
donate to our workers a brave brave
decision has been reached here
Stuart quote look there's poverty and
sadness all over the planet but I felt
that if I was really going to do work I
should start to to do work in the place
where our employees work and live that
would be most meaningful Stuart brave
brave Stuart so lost picture oh there it
is Wow yeah that looks that looks shitty
the workers in the valley got college
scholarships and tutors a new school
being built linda is of course designing
the curriculum oh good okay so you're
taking pom 101 it's about all about
pomegranate and we're gonna do thing
about how great fiji water is and then
why immigrants are just rude
also why it's good to lower the minimum
wage paper water better than real water
you can drink it yeah there's a free
Wellness Center and free fruits and
veggies put out for the workers
Linda decided to get rid of the nacho
chips french fries and soft drinks the
workers weren't happy about it
so the residents started to begin to
sell wellness to their 4,300 employees
this is just I mean this is not
this is Jones Tony now drink the
kool-aid it's a second that you're
offering your own what like that's the
problem with the term wellness formula
like I have a wellness formula you know
I'm making it of that they so they did
stuff like they built though they built
a park they get bonuses for the workers
and I should not have watched sorry to
bother you a movie it's now like well
what are you talking about we've made
wonderful Park they get bonuses for
losing weight 1150 workers have earned
bonuses up to $500 for losing a
collective 14,000 pounds between all of
them over two years you know where
that's not happening is Venezuela doing
pay breaks music starts blaring and they
do 15 minutes of Zumba where they are I
think Teletubby has less weird laws
Teletubby lay on quote a few dozen
seasonal employees wearing orange
reflective vests and hair nets at around
folding tables evaluating samples from
incoming truckloads of pistachios
suddenly a boombox started blaring
merengue and everyone stood up and
danced it was the daily Zumba break at
the cafeteria Spanish rice isn't rice
but cauliflower that looks like rice
pizza dough is cauliflower - she's
making him eat what sheets Dave she's
making them do the Zumba which you know
she does Dave it's honestly taking on a
dark turn after work a 10-hour workday
they are pushed to workout in the
fitness center for an hour and they do
it there a trainer watches the workers
want the cash bonuses from the companies
get fit living in a timeshare
it's like a timeshare meeting it's okay
so it's not is working out good for them
yes sure is eating healthy good for them
yes sure
but also if you're making minimum wage
[ __ ] it though one of the only Joy's you
have is eating the food you like not
cauliflower [ __ ] rice like you're
already [ __ ] also let them have their
little moments of [ __ ] but it's also
easy to do that it's also easy to insist
on 15 minutes oomba breaks when your
life is breaks yeah totally and so
you're just like hey everybody do zoom
yeah they have no they have no idea what
these people's lives yeah so most of
these people came from northern Mexico
where their farm towns were taken over
by cartels a lot of people were
slaughtered in those towns and they fled
to get to America they'd have to pay
coyotes to cross the border the price
now is twelve thousand dollars a head
which the families they get a cousin
over then they pay off together over
years so out of their meager wages
they're saving up money to pay off the
coyote so they can never get ahead so
they will take the hundred dollars that
they get for working out for a year cuz
they have to oh you're paid to work out
well that's as the incentive she pays
them and they need money so badly
because their lives have been so [ __ ]
so by the way cauliflower is very
versatile so so it means yeah so it
means they do give video zoom but in the
middle of a [ __ ] pistachio field
they'll do it which has got to be the
most humiliating thing I can [ __ ]
think of like I just cannot imagine well
you you are just I mean you are in like
a delusional paradise yeah but they
still live in Train boxcars that were
turned into housing and their water
comes out of a tap that is and it is
yellow and foul-smelling they do not
drink it that is sort of the beauty of
the capitalists dream is that they spent
so long telling you that your tap water
was [ __ ] long enough to make you
believe it so they turned your water
into - oh well the water there is a
[ __ ] nightmare an 11 year old girl
quote it comes out like pee they spend
$50 a month or more on bottled water
still wish there's a way around which
there was something that the residents
could do anyway in 2014 Stephen should
show them a documentary about the
Resnick's right yeah in 2014 Stephen
Colbert did a Super Bowl ad for the
Resnick's pistachios
members head comes open in the session
pistachio sales more than doubled in
three months sales increased the
following year to reach 114 million in
more than sorry in 2015 the Resnick's
rebranded all their holdings from role
international to the wonderful company
to highlight their focus on healthy
products and fluent philanthropy linda
quote our company has always believed
that success means doing well by doing
good no it hasn't no no she said there's
that she has a name they named it so
there's the school they were making Prep
Academy oh my god what Jesus Christ
they're people they're great people oh
look at that
you know they should be sentenced to
drowning 2015 it was revealed that for
20 years
the Resnick's and other farmers had been
watering their archers with treated frac
wadding wastewater
ah that's right right
fracking wastewater wastewater is a
byproduct of fracking it is being
treated and sold to farmers who use it
to water their crops which are then sold
in grocery stores to human beings as the
brutal drought wore on farmers used more
and more oil wastewater California
officials praised using oil wastewater
to grow vegetables but some think it's
not exactly safe well and these people
who are flagging it I don't sort of
acing this upon the I don't believe by
the way it's gonna be really interesting
like you know the next 30 years you know
we give us are gonna be really
fascinating because there's gonna be a
lot of fun mutations going on
you know x-men's gonna watch like a
documentary in 20 years just well people
have been like living on fracked food
right and then people say well the EPA's
being [ __ ] by Trump but it's already
[ __ ] oh yeah it's already a [ __ ]
disaster guys there no one's doing [ __ ]
about anything I mean sure they do a lot
of stuff but it's so [ __ ] bad
absolutely I mean look at the amount of
look it flinty the amount of pollution
that is allowed to just be and of course
it's getting worse but it has it's like
everything else it's kind of like if
you're a president you're what you're
really doing is biding your time what is
going to be part of your problem and
what is gonna be part of this next guy's
problem or like a guy thirty years down
the line and we unfortunately are at the
breaking point of this problem with the
worst person possible but it has been
created the corrosive the corrosive
nature of all this goes back pages yeah
decades yeah mm-hmm so for instance
benzene turned up in the wastewater but
the state has set no standard for
benzene irrigation water after
complaints the water board started
requiring the water to water board the
water board yes requests requiring the
water be tested for toxicity a committee
to determine if chemicals in the water
quote pose a threat to public health at
the concentrations detected yeah let's
see now let's do that twenty years after
we started doing it yeah that's when we
should do that for sure yeah no find out
it's time California's safety
consultants are concerned quote current
water district requirements for testing
such waters before they are used for
irrigation are not sufficient no one
knows what chemicals fracking companies
use so they don't know what to test for
as fracking companies I don't think
anywhere does any government force any
fracking company to disclose chemicals
they use because copyright law why would
they why would they why would you want
to know that why would you want to know
what you're blasting into earth some of
the crops being grown with fracking
water are subview subview raisins that
well that's probably wrong but Sutter
Home wines and wonderful citrus mm-hmm
halos hmm journalist journalist Yasha
Levin he went down there
here's the pools Oh God
here's this quote to really appreciate
the toxicity of this place all you have
to do is stand by the mixing ponds where
the oil waste is magically turned in
that is so much worse than I would have
imagined into clean irrigation water a
whiff of the raw petroleum and Cam's
makes your heads that's the water that
is being used like I mean essentially
it's like huffing glue he said so they
put it in different pools and they move
it from pool to pool and that's supposed
to clean up the water so it's different
pools but they're just moving the water
through but they're putting the fracking
water suit through at least what they're
saying is of course a nice you see the
dark one and then the next one yeah the
next one so that's how they're cleaning
it they all look pretty dark and then
crude oil and water
oh god what who they're asked to draw
that on something you're like no that
makes no sense
Wow so they're using this water to all
their [ __ ] all the farmers because
there's a drought and and at the same
time the government was cracking down on
fracking companies about how to get rid
of wastewater so you know agriculture it
all worked out but but the that is part
of the problem is that like when you
have when you do squeeze farmers to the
sixth it's like what Monsanto does it's
like at some piece guys aren't being
squeezed they don't know the farmer like
local farmer like when local farmers
have to like make decisions they are
going to make compromise yes to survive
and I don't know how I don't know I mean
the number of local farmers in the San
Joaquin Valley and the minute I probably
very small okay and this is Agri
business has destroyed everybody the
rednecks thirst for water shows no sign
of ending they have used front groups
and political pressure to try to get
even more water from Northern
California's dogs dam the biggest thing
holding it all up is a fish called the
delta smelt the smelt our consumer smelt
it dealt it that's right the smells are
considered an indicator species used to
gauge the overall health of the deltas
aquatic hey I'm gonna get out of here
and when you because I'm sure this is
gonna be a pretty light fact
gonna actually get out of here before
you you say this one I'm just gonna walk
out with a pretty optimistic view as the
smelt goes so go the other fish species
in the Delta lawsuits over the
livelihood of the delta smelt have kept
more water from being pumped out of the
Delta so the the smelt was basically
saving the Delta but it's also doin
dling every year that I learned about
the delta smelt when I was in college in
in the [ __ ] early 90s like the delta
smelt like with the delta smelt goes
down so to the santa so to the salmon
and if the salmon go down they don't
just go down at san francisco it affects
the whole [ __ ] westcote like it the
double smell is a big [ __ ] deal
so a group called the coalition of a
coalition for sustainable Delta started
filing lawsuits to assign blame for the
estuaries decline it blamed everything
from farming housing development
dredging power plant sport fishing and
pollution but not but not big AG farming
in the valley farming up north near the
Delta weird the coalition originally
listed a paramount farms fax number and
three of the four officers on its early
tax documents were Reznick employees
it's so simple I mean you just at some
point you're just too cocky
yeah but they can get away with it yeah
that's what I mean yeah what do you care
the hell I would yeah you may as well
let Linda do everything after judges
ruled in favor of the smelt the
Resnick's started reaching out to
politicians whom they had given tons of
money to over the years seven hundred
thirty four thousand two governor Gray
Davis two hundred and seventy thousand
two Schwarzenegger 150 thousand that
Jerry Brown plus two hundred fifty
thousand to his pet education project
tons of money everywhere Senator Dianne
Feinstein who chairs the Senate
Appropriations Committee a powerful
energy and water panel and spent a new
years at the Resnick Aspen House tried
to help out the senator asked the
Interior and Commerce agencies to
re-examine the science behind the delta
smelt environmental protection plan the
agencies then spent seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars to come to the exact
same conclusion that researchers had two
thousand and seven restrictions on Delta
pumping were warranted so because Diane
finds Santa's friends they just wasted
7-iron fifty
dollars of our money must be a nice
guest room Linda says that they wield no
political power when it comes to water
policy quote we have no influential
influence politically I swear to you and
nobody has a political dream nor would
we use it no no do we use it no now why
would you
Governor Brown began pushing for a 15
billion dollar plan to construct two
40-foot wide tunnels to carry 76,000
gallons of water per second from the
Sacramento River to the Central Valley
the Resnick's then launched Californians
for water security a group of business
people backing the tunnels so they just
started releasing all these ads and they
said it was about safety it was about
what if earthquakes happen what are we
gonna do they just saw this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that had nothing to do with the
fact that like they just want to [ __ ]
put pistachios everywhere mm-hmm 2016
palm hits us kids the juice top-selling
after the FTC had found wonderful guilty
of false advertising and order the
Resnick's to stop making false health
claims their tanks at the plant were
filled with a three-year supply and the
state's worst drought was having an
effect no no the Residex had gone
through their allotment and the water
bank and the state water supplies had
gone to almost zero for the farms the
pomegranate orchards were now being
bulldozed up to ten thousand trees by
2016 but the Resnick's were still
watering a lot of their orchards how
well remember that guy John Vidic
yeah the guy who stood in front of the
plane he was good for a minute that he'd
turned bad yeah that guy yeah he he was
going around buying up tons of land
right I think he has like a hundred
thousand acres of land now it's all near
water it's all very very select places
and he was the guy who's gonna sue him
but then didn't mm-hmm well he had
bought land in nearby Kings County and
he was selling Stewart water from the
Dudley Ridge water district he was
selling everyone water he's not a farmer
he buys land and sells water or paper
water that's all he does he literally at
one point in one interview said that
he's doing it to show farmers that what
they're doing is unsustainable
what a dick so wonderful is buying up
fifty thousand acre-feet of water a year
in a bunch of hidden secret deals in
some of the waters coming from farmers
in the two-layer Lake Basin who are
pumping so much out of the ground that
the levees protecting the town of
Cochran are sinking by feet to fix the
subsidence and keep the town dry in the
next flood residents and the state
prison are having to pay ten million
dollars in extra taxes so these farmers
are taking water out of the ground and
just selling it to whoever the [ __ ] they
want and now the town has to pay ten
million dollars because everything's
getting so [ __ ] up from the land
collapsing at the same time the
Resnick's had bought three hundred
thousand acre feet of water for two
hundred million dollars from different
people so john vltava CH was one selling
to the Resnick's but he had already been
sued by nearby farmers in king kings
county for taking too much water out of
the ground and moving it yeah the court
settlement states water cannot go
outside Kings County ok
but the Resnick's had a pipeline going
to King's County and taking the water ok
vide [ __ ] quote they drink our oil
Resnick's Resnick picks up the water and
Dudley Ridge it's his pipe not mine
where he takes the waters none of my
business
uh-huh oh god damn it this should all
take place in the Cayman Islands after
Resnick learned a report I discovered
the pipeline he had it removed all the
right reasons
now now that the valley has been sinking
forever and here's a picture from the
70s so that's a guy from national he's a
geographer so ok so that's where the
land was in 1925 ok in 1955 and now 9
wait that's where the water was that's
where the land was the land was ok so
the land has sunk a telephone size right
a telephone-pole-sized crazy of human
down at the he down at the human bottom
there
what so it's still been it's still been
sinking every year since 1977 it keeps
going to a hard thing to fathom during
the strike the sinking was insane feet
and feet and feet so all the pumping of
Aquos aquifers has everyone to have to
dig deeper to find water a raisin farmer
in summer had a well that ran dry he
said quote Reznick my old well can't
compete with his new wells I have to go
deeper if I can so he drives people out
of business
because if you're a farmer and you're
living on the edge and you have to keep
digging deeper that means each well cost
more and and what was thirty thousand
it's not two hundred fifty thousand
she's trying to keep up with the [ __ ]
and eventually you can't keep up with
the [ __ ] so much water is being
pulled out of aquifers that the state is
sinking the sinking is destroying
bridges cracking irrigation canals and
twisting highways some places in the
state are sinking more than a foot per
year railroads bridges highways wells
everything is being damaged instead of
recording it the different companies or
whatever and just go out and fix that
one issue and then move on to the next
one sure perfect yeah don't worry about
removing the disease fix the finger it
started raining again in autumn of 2016
and the state water project for the
first time in six years had a surplus
what wonderful could irrigate its
orchards again and even put more in the
water Bank the Resnick's started
planting all the trees where they had
dug them up of the 22,000 acres they
ripped up during the drought 18,000
acres are being replanted as pistachios
oh god damn it
well obviously there's one big lesson no
more pistachios unless you're in Iran
where hey they're very very good very
buttery they also decided to get into
the wine business and pass the roubles
they bought land and then brought in
bulldozers and started tearing up the
hillside destroying thousands of
California oak trees people were furious
restaurants up and down the coast said
they would boycott the Resnick's wine
and then the media was alerted and then
the Resnick's claimed they were sorry
quote when we learned of the terrible
situation not to mention our poor
reputation within the community we were
ashamed and are sorry that's not how
shame is supposed to work we were asleep
at the wheel we were horrified by the
lack of a guard I'm gonna throw up a
bucket Aaron our neighbor and nature we
hope that the community will accept our
deepest and most sincere apology level
of ego that's at the heart of this
apology and find it in their hearts to
forgive us oh my god they pledge tonight
to donate the 388 acres to charity but
the oak the Oaks the hundred-year-old
Oaks or more yeah are gone you know they
just destroy a forest but Dave they're
sorry once people found out and they
knew they felt bad
that's not how conscience is supposed to
work once people got angry at us we felt
bad once everyone knew our secrets we
were guilty I love the way it's written
they act like it just something that
happened they didn't reputation in an
apology about destroying nature you're
the level of your reputation should be
something you can at least bite your
[ __ ] lip through yeah so god damn I
am like I want to frame this picture and
just get a punching bag the state of
California has adopted a new law that
finally regulates pumping yeah but when
it goes into a full effect in a decade
or two
oh god more than a million acres of
cropland across the valley will have to
be retired but then how much water will
be left in those aquifers now in October
it can be refilled but when an aquifer
dries up then it turns into a substance
that it like it's like it's almost like
I think the way it's been described to
me is it's like a hard clay that then
crumbles and now you can't refill right
but as long as it's got something
something I can only fill it but once
it's no one sits empty you can't refill
right the Resnick's own a hundred and
eighty thousand acres of California 281
square miles is the largest farmer in
the country I believe well he looks like
a farmer 121 thousand of those acres are
irrigated the Resnick's use more water
than any other person in the West there
are 15 million trees consumed more than
4,400 thousand acre feet of water a year
the entire city of Los Angeles consumes
587 thousand acres a year oh my god
Linda on the company quote if you call
yourself the wonderful company you'd
better damn well be wonderful right
are you asking Linda are you asking my
god so when people say there's a water
problem in California there isn't a
water problem in California and when
people say is a human property yeah
there's a human problem people say that
in the North they're stealing our water
in in Southern California no or not the
people are stealing the water are these
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then they do a good
job of making you think it's these other
situations yeah they make it seem like
everybody else laughs although when we
fight each other about the water and
these [ __ ] is the state should
be regulating what you can plant without
question and you should be using things
like cotton and stuff that does not use
tons of water and you and you have and
you use a variety of [ __ ] foods out
there but it should not be [ __ ] loads of
the worst [ __ ] crop for water in a
place where you need water and you know
you take the water bank back you go in
there with [ __ ] guns and you say the
water bank is ours now [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I mean seriously [ __ ] these [ __ ]
people you [ __ ] sent a [ __ ] police
force in there and you say [ __ ] off it's
our [ __ ] water now that's the whole
thing that's like we talk about this all
the time like moving the line forward as
far as what you feel from a calamity
like if you were able to right now be
like hey we're out of water well then
obviously you're gonna go to their place
with guns and be like knock this [ __ ]
off but until there's something on the
back there's still or something like
actually on people's front porch it's
just like oh well it sucks and you see
how many pistachios are now and my wife
loves pistachios and and I tell her this
and she goes what kind of naughty
pistachios anymore and I said it doesn't
matter yeah it they they own so much so
they're beyond boycott the only way to
stop them is for the government to come
in and stop them they're beyond anything
that we could do is people that's
frustrating that's where they are
and my wife goes what well what would
you do I said I would get a gas truck
and I would drive it through their
orchards spray the gas they were and set
them on fire
shouldn't talk about that okay well I'm
just not gonna eat it if that's okay but
there but that's it like this is what
monopoly is this is what when a business
gets too big that unless the government
wants to stop them but they pay for the
government the government is because
Diane Rice's [ __ ] up and when
Diane Feinstein when Barbara Boxer was
leaving office
she was always involved in in in
negotiations with water and the day she
was leaving office Dianne Feinstein went
behind her back and made a deal with
Republicans to [ __ ] everybody over for
the Central Valley [ __ ] farmers and
Barbara Boxer was [ __ ] livid but
Dianne Feinstein is the government have
to ever work with you again but these
are my bees people give me money so she
[ __ ] everybody also they're all
[ __ ] people the [ __ ] water tunnels
I believe they're done now I believe
that they they there's been enough
things against them that they cannot
happen but if those water tunnels go
through the [ __ ] delta smelt are done
and if the delta smelt die all the fish
all the way up the chain [ __ ] die
it's not like a thing that you have to
worry about one fish it's all the
goddamn fish well and you also don't
know you know I mean it's what we're
about to find out the ramifications of
what happens when things in nature that
are underappreciated go away what are
the ramifications yeah and that's going
to be you know a very difficult time
yeah you'll miss the days when you've
thought a crazy lady thought that you
could just command bees when your kids
will be like what are bees there's a guy
and gives a TED talk about what happened
when wolves were reintroduced to
Yellowstone oh right and if you want to
know how nature works together go listen
to that TED talk and literally the river
changed shape that's how much
introducing an animal back into an
ecosystem makes a difference it changed
the river shape go listen to how it
happened when we take an animal out it
doesn't matter what animal it is we're
[ __ ] ourselves
you're all so yeah please join Planet
change tan tan PLA
a new way to change 10 we're on Twitter
and by the way if you guys wanna know
update on that I'm still working on I've
been so [ __ ] busy because of the
holidays and also the ship but we're
gonna go with some companies to get the
website done and to get how we can talk
to everybody at once and but that's the
biggest thing it's communication and
having everyone's numbers and
information stored so that's what
working on now look maybe got a good
feeling well people wanted more
environmental ones well oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I
probably should have said this earlier
maybe open this up top
Jasha Levin the guy who went to the oil
fields he has I think I put it away
Yasha Levin has a Kickstarter you should
do this at the top yeah but do it now
but yeah I'll do yeah sure Levin has a
Kickstarter he is a journalist who has
been writing about the Central Valley
water situation for a while he wants to
make a documentary and has a Kickstarter
up the project is called pistachio Wars
oh man killing California for a snack
food please donate this is super [ __ ]
important story
this documentary needs to get made and
I've read a lot of this guy's stuff this
is the guy to make it so please pistacia
war is killing California for a snack
food go to the Kickstarter and give
Jesus Christ how long was that okay
No then God shut it down okay thanks for
this into the dock